now it's been three years since the
creation of one of your most iconic
moments the sorry to this man meme sorry
to this man
oh my gosh yes
yes the internet is so spectacular the
way that they can take things that you
say out of context it literally blows my
mind it's the coolest thing in the world
so seeing the remixes of and who the
hell are they are absolutely hilarious
if anyone knows how cool the internet is
it's kiki she is the first ever
metaverse host a little confused well
that's why we teamed up with kiki and
metta to learn more about their new show
are we there yet can you give it to me
straight and simple what is the
metaverse so the metaverse is a virtual
reality and it's not to be confused with
taking over our current reality but more
so a graduation of what we know as the
internet today you can go to a comedy
club you can go to a concert you can
hang out with your friends and you
pretty much are taking that experience
you have online and making it a little
bit more realistic are you ready to get
on the virtual road are we there yet to
me it does exactly what i always want to
do which just inform everybody about all
the great things that are happening
digitally the metaverse is allowing us
as creatives to really have limitless
possibilities you put on that vr headset
and it enhances your social media and
digital experience but it's really
called are we there yet because it's
talking about the future of the
metaverse right you know this show is
really to encourage all the creators out
here to know that this is a space out
here for you and the more that we're
engaged with it the better we can make
it the fuller that it becomes so we want
to play an etv game tell us if these
things are happening now in the future
or never in the metaverse now future or
never a hollywood red carpet on the moon
can we do that in the metaverse yeah
that's now now okay
what about we're getting complicated
riding a unicorn to an album release
party yes absolutely now can we learn
french
while heading to a movie premiere that's
being held at the eiffel tower i mean
yes i think some i think a lot of that
is now because you can probably do two
functions at once so i'm gonna say it's
now with maybe like a dash of future
you